[Music]
so my name is Thomas Martin I'm the
founder and CEO of big Co small Co and
so we are a technology integrator that
brings start-up technology and
innovative technologies to the big
company enterprise previously I was a
CEO and CTO across multiple GE
industrial businesses and had the
pleasure of leading the effort to
migrate over 9,000 workloads to public
cloud and today I'm here with Brian
Johnson hi my name is Brian Johnson I'm
the CEO and co-founder at Divi cloud
prior to taking on this journey I worked
at Electronic Arts for about
seven-and-a-half years working on
massive multiplayer online games
deploying a lot of those games around
data centers around the world and led
the charge into migration into cloud
with about 2013 very cool so through
that process of the migration one of the
things that we thought was really
interesting is that as we adopted cloud
we started treating it like a technology
problem but at the end of the day that
actually wasn't the case right the other
day was actually a culture problem and
what we realized is that shift to
self-service was incredibly important
for our ability to compete all of our
competitors are out there building games
and doing it much faster and getting
those products to market and learning
from their customers and building really
cool games how could we continue to do
that how could we continue to innovate
well we couldn't do that if IT continue
to get in the way so we needed to find a
way to allow our engineering
organizations to access cloud to be able
to deploy applications to innovate
through their cloud infrastructure
without security and IT really getting
in a way of that and through that
process what we discovered is it wasn't
just a technology problem right it was
actually three things that came together
in this sort of perfect storm that
caused an issue for security number one
yeah yeah we were moving with more right
just more everything we have more
servers so we were moving from you know
500 was all that was not the actual
number thousands of servers to tens and
twenty thousands of instances inside of
AWS so that in GCP so that was really
interesting through that process and
then we also had this mechanism where
number of people touching the
infrastructure dramatically increased it
wasn't just the IT staff anymore it was
thousands of engineers all over the
globe touching infrastructure and
deploying applications which led to
third thing we were no longer server
huggers right we were basically having
change every day see ICD process one
little code change a bug fix tear
everything down rebuild it back again so
that led to just a dramatic increase in
the number of changes that were
occurring in the infrastructure to give
a moment so these three things combined
number of resources you had to manage
number of people touching those
resources and how often those resources
were changing led to this incredibly
difficult problem how did we deal with
this scale how could we possibly as an
organization understand everything that
was changing and react to it in any
reasonable amount of time based on
traditional IT and security processes we
had in place which were super slow so
that was really the problem we see out
there this is not a technology it's a
company transformation issue how do you
get ahead of this and how do you deal
with scale so with that let's just kind
of talk about me what does this really
begin to mean from a practical aspect
right I mean fairly simple right this is
just a simple three two your
architecture the miss the opportunities
actually seem quite small right I mean
you've just got a couple you've got a
load balancer a couple computes you know
spanning across a couple of a couple of
availability zones we've got a cloud
storage and cloud sequel the point is is
if you're just managing and it's in a
small scale with a single team not all
that hard right but really when you
start looking at it there's at least 20
plus opportunities for miss
configuration just in this simple
three-tier architecture think about that
when you begin to migrate say five seven
ten thousand applications across an
enterprise to try to manage this at any
kind of scale just becomes unwielding
and what I found was actually for
ourselves in my past experience has
really been somewhere between about a
hundred and 200 applications the team
this the whole structure starts to fall
down you really have to begin to think
about not only is that CI CD process so
important but it's really about all the
configurations not only real-time
aprende deployment but ongoing and on
forward so what does this lead to
well in our case it led to a couple of
different things led to loss of control
right we're letting engineers go and
sort of deploy that's a great thing
right you
want that innovation that innovation in
order to survive as a company you've got
to find a way to compete through
innovation so absolutely important but
you lose control right it used to be
that any change was gonna be made in the
infrastructure went through us first so
we would know a problem we would see a
mistake we'd be able to stop a map
that's not necessarily the case anymore
and furthermore what interesting is this
the all things considered so it means
that you went from having an IT
organization who had awesome place to be
able to catch these issues do the sort
of controls and gateways they had two
engineers just doing all sorts of things
all over the place and the problem is
nobody ever sat down the engineering
organization explained to him twenty
years of history tough security issues
that we hit it's not like IT learned
that stuff the easy way and we got
compromised we had problems we had
issues since we learned build processes
unfortunate processes really slowed us
down and the other thing we've
recognized is when we started to move
towards a more cloud native approach
we're like well we'll just do alerting
we'll just basically get alerts every
time there's something we need to pay
attention to that really quickly got out
of control
I mean it just became whack-a-mole there
was just no way to keep up with it I
have alert fatigue on here's what we
talked about and that is getting those
slack message or emails and how do you
know when to pay attention to what are
the important areas because the reality
is of 20,000 changes now you're dealing
with there's gonna be one of those it
might be really important and you may
have a hard time identifying which one
of those you need to pay attention to so
really this is really about a signal and
noise problem with all these things
going on how do you reduce all of the
noise so that you can focus on the
signal and at the end of the day it have
to leverage automation to do that
there's just no way that we leverage
traditional IT process to use a runbook
to correct problems to contact the perch
to talk to them about making the change
by the time that's occurred the
application has been torn down and
redeployed three times right so you need
to be able to get rid of the noise
leveraging automation so that your IT
staff so your security staff so you're
set up your cloud offs have the ability
to focus on that ten percent that they
need to be with dealing with on a more
annual and active basis and so with that
I mean you really start to look at and
say that traditional IT perimeter and
processes that we've always used and
relied upon
are ineffective you just can't handle
those kind of changes it's scale they're
still important I'm not I'm not
mitigating the fact of perimeter control
we're gonna talk a little bit more about
that about how that begins to fold in
but it's really so important
particularly as Brian talked about to be
able to filter out the noise and so you
know as you step back and think about it
for those of you who are working those
large enterprise firms is you know think
about at least for me the IT procurement
process our development teams literally
had they knew in their head probably an
extra 60 to 90 days in the schedule they
they committed but they figured by the
time things get through procurement
backlog of servers making it to the data
center by the time they get it in they
rack it put it in put up the operating
system get it network we're looking at
somewhere between 90 120 days I've even
seen as long as 180 days to get procured
services into the data center and so
those kind of processes as Brian was
talk about when you're standing up
something to try to detect it and
resolve it that resource may have
already been built and gone and I know
you certainly experienced that a TA yeah
I mean certainly I mean if we weighed
180 days games get built and thrown away
in hundred eighty days right so you have
to be able to move more quickly I think
the other thing we saw was not just the
time it took to provision I mean that
certainly took a lot of time and I'm
never gonna rack another server again
but but certainly the other thing we saw
was just when you were going through
this process and working with
engineering and trying to talk about the
problems are gonna face when they start
to adopt cloud and you're going to that
transformation sometimes people don't
understand the scale of the attack
surface and so what I mean is the
offensive nature of what's going on out
there so we used to have an exercise we
do with our engineers they come on board
we'd have them deploy a server into a
secured environment where port 20 to be
open to the world and completely public
accessible and we just set like route
route on password and login and we just
having time it how long does it take
before that box gets popped and
sometimes when you go through the
exercise it opens your eyes to the
amount of things that are just out there
scanning and looking and trying to find
ways in I mean when you know 10 or 12
years ago there was an increase in the
amount of sophisticated exploits are
being developed that's actually started
dovetailed
a little bit primarily cuz it's not
necessary anymore people were out there
opening up s3 buckets or leaving
databases open in the world I know that
hasn't happened yeah those things and so
it's not necessary to spend time and
energy and resources and those really
complex exploits when you can just scan
and find a way in and so that's part of
this equation is not only understanding
as security professionals what scale
looks like internally but also training
the engineering organization about
what's important about security how they
need to deploy how they need to think
about people trying to get in because
you can help teach them as they go
through this process
everyone's gonna race like everything's
gonna get better at you're gonna get
faster and more innovative well just
think about your own SLA is right I mean
what would be an SLA from you know a
typical event in a data center to when
you're gonna respond to it how much data
could be lost if you had that you know
that cloud storage open to the world so
those are those are the things to think
about and so how do you begin to to
really think about it from a remediation
standpoint right so the first off is it
needs to be near real-time right so as
you go around it's really starting at a
harvesting point so utilizing all the
access points those api's across all
those resources and harvesting them back
real-time not only upon creation but
actually upon change it's that day to
drift to also think about things might
have been great as you deployed at other
CI CD tool change but what happened
after that point with that engineer I I
honestly don't think in item 1 I really
don't believe people intentionally do a
lot of the configuration mistakes they
do but it's that middle the night day to
ops when something's wrong I'll change
that back as soon as it's resolved and
it doesn't get resolved it doesn't get
flipped back right so do you first got
to harvest that data back in then you
want to unify it so that it's consistent
across all of your individual accounts
all of your V pcs all those resources
are then normalized into a single data
plane then you want to drive analysis
against it so as you thought about
establishing those compliance and
security policies of what does it mean
to our organization to be compliant
that's the analysis that gets done
real-time against those resources and
then being able to take action what do I
want to have happen when this occurs so
it's that if then this scenario if port
22 is open to the world what
I want to do who do I want to wake up
what immediate action do I want to take
not only to protect the company but also
from a forensics perspective as well as
to learn right was it the team that
inadvertently did it to resolve an issue
or were we actually breached so all that
data is captured and dumped off for
analytics so ahead yeah one thing Hans
your thymine everyone saw this morning's
announcement right about the multi-cloud
push from Google this is absolutely the
right way to go I'm super excited about
they're doing the center doing on top of
kubernetes kubernetes is going to be the
element that breaks down the barriers
and commoditize as infrastructure and so
at the end of the day it's going to be
really important from the enterprise
organization perspective and you're
looking at the infrastructure layer that
you can have a unified because you're
gonna have engineers who were using
Azure you're gonna have engineers who
are using GCP you're gonna have
engineers using Amazon and you can't
build policies they're gonna be just
living in those worlds because you're
gonna forget about them or they're gonna
sort of die on the vine or in different
ways to go on and as we know in security
it doesn't matter if you have 95%
coverage that 5% is the one that's going
to get you so you need to make sure you
have a create holistic strategy and
holistic policy as you move move forward
so how do you do that well there's a
lots of different ways to think about
dealing with this using remediation one
is you know a development environment
your remediation might be slightly
different than as your production
environment and your development
environment you look engineer you want
to do some latency testing I worked for
a big bank we are not allowed to have
servers outside the United States but
you want to do some latency testing so
in the development environment you can
have an instance in Asia pack for the
next two hours two hours later our
system's gonna automatically come back
and clean it up make sure everything's
ok but when you move that same
application the staging you may not
actually have that ability to do that
you might leverage more go faster
remediation the server comes on in Asia
back it's killed instantly right but you
still want to let them have that ability
to try new services and do more things
right you don't want to lock them down
using preventive controls because you
need them to go in there and try any
things you need them to innovate and if
you block them at the light at the top
layer they're just gonna go around you
they'll go create an account try it
themselves and that's the worst thing
you can be in being compromised is bad
being compromising not knowing it if it
were
right so embrace this help them innovate
help them learn goes to that process
with them and leverage your mediation in
real time to be able to provide
flexibility about how they do that but
then when you get to production this is
where you may want to leverage some
preventative controls the cloud device
today provide different ways to do
preventative controls and lock down
certain services are being used so as
you're taking your engineer through this
journey right you want them to each
stage understand it's a little bit more
stringent it's a little bit tighter it's
a little bit harder to do what you're
gonna do beside the parameters of what
we've approved so when they get
production it just doesn't work right
but they're not surprised by the time
they get there because the whole way
through the journey you've been teaching
them and what's more important about
that is it's not just about enforcing a
policy and they're just running away
right it's about engaging them it's
about bringing into the conversation
okay what is it you're trying to
accomplish what are you trying to do let
me help you find a secure way of doing
that help them innovate and help them
along that journey let me interject
there Brian's gonna talk about on the
next slide but think about it too is
it's it's as he's mentioned this funnel
of restriction you're providing
guardrails that are much wider in that
early stage to generate innovation but
by the time you are at stage 3 its its
its least privileged right it in fact in
many cases it's just gonna be machine
only privileges that are enabled in
production to be able to to run those
services and so we'll talk here in the
next layer about how you get there yeah
yeah so let's talk about these different
layers it's sort of like you almost
thinking about super fine-grained up to
a more coarse grain right so when you're
what we call protect mode right this is
where you're leveraging real-time
remediation to go and clean up after
things or things down or clean up
security groups whatever it might be
right
identified databases that have not been
connected to in a long time all those
different elements are going in and
cleaning up fixing that kind of stuff
and you're protecting your armored on a
regular basis then you have your implied
checks right so this is your ability to
take things like terraform or cloud
formation templates or anything you need
to work with to be able to deploy into
your environment and provision maybe
Hellman shart ray bill deploy into that
infrastructure and have the engineers
integrate with a tool that will allow it
to check those things as they're doing
it so when they're going through the CI
CD process
it checks them of the system and goes
hey I'm about to build these ten
resources is what it looks like is this
okay
right have the CI CD process then either
pass it and say yeah you're allowed to
do this cuz its development but we're
gonna tell you this is a problem or or
have it just straight fail to build
right you want to integrate and bring
security into their world not the other
way around again if you try and do that
there's gonna find it annoying and go
around you so how do you go how do you
bring it in right
so those imply checks are really
important and then finally these the
serve link spaces this idea that as you
provision accounts you do in an
automated fashion and when you do that
for projects or teams or whatever might
be you go in and start slapping controls
around it at provision time and this
might be a mixture of remediation and
preventative measures
you might enforce some sort of ability
worth to a CI CD pipeline where it's
game checked as it goes all those sort
of tighten things around as you go into
a more production and preventative
matrix myth that accounts there we go
and really and so there's really go in
combination right so those those
coarse-grained are those big mindsets
that say these are never you know never
to you know be violated if you will down
to that mid grain where as Brian talked
about you may put a warning there in
that dev cycle but you're not going to
shut it down immediately because you
also are facing into that cultural shift
right so you also want to educate
engineering as to why we are going that
direction down to those fine-grained
controls that not only take care of upon
launch but really that drift that it can
occur day to day 30 so those really
combined with some of the things that we
talked about on the previous slide
around the cycle aspect gives us so for
those of the leaders in the room gives
us that ability to become more the
Department of yes to drive innovation
for your company versus the Department
of no look I think the the the high
level key takeaway here is that as
everyone goes down this journey you need
to define a strategy for the
organization hey you can't just not a so
I we started out talking about the back
this is not just a technology problem
this is how a business is going to
transform when I was at a and we are
building games the introduction of cloud
didn't just change how we deployed our
applications it literally changed what
applications we built it changed what
games we took the market it changed
which games we decided to stop
developing on because we're able to do
it faster right so it's a huge business
transformation so as you go through this
process you decide how sick
how IT how cloud office is gonna address
this it's important to think about as a
holistic strategy right so we talk about
that those layers you know all the way
from development and the production
needs to be could take into
consideration and how you engage your
engineering staff and teach them as they
go absolutely and I think as Brian
mentioned earlier around filtering out
the noise we can't rely on the
traditional just the perimeter security
control and just providing notification
okay it's great to know that there's a
theft happening in Aisle five but have
we filtered out the noise to know
exactly where in pinpoint what's what is
happening where it's happening and how
to resolve it and then be able to take
that action to remediate it in a time of
cloud speed the other so we're out there
on regular basis working large
enterprise customers solving for this
strategic problem and one of the things
that we've found is the companies that
tend to have most success we're able to
get moving quickest have an established
cloud ops team rate what this is sort of
interesting because when we talk about
security there's this desire to think
about traditional infrastructure
security this is about analyzing network
traffic and identifying external threats
and coming up with preventative measures
to react to those threats but the
security problem we're facing right now
is different than what we've seen before
I used to do exploit development
professionally for a while and so from
the offensive side you're thinking about
things slightly different you think
about how to get into a black box from
the security side when you're defending
against add you're looking at traffic to
try and figure out what people are
throwing at you what do they know about
you that you don't know and so on and so
forth when you're dealing with the cloud
ops side of things and helping
engineering teams grow it's much more
about understanding what they're doing
and what their needs are making sure
they don't make mistakes it's an
internal threat it's very different
because it turns out you and then we're
on the same side right you know fighting
one another so you have to find a way to
embrace that and what we've found is by
establishing a cloud center of
excellence a cloud ops team that's going
to be focused on security from a cloud
perspective and what that means to the
internal organization means you get a
lot more innovation a lot quicker I
think to add to that is my experience
has also been is that having that focal
team that cloud ops team also helps as
an accelerant not only from an adoption
perspective but also from an educational
cultural perspective across the entire
organization
as folks begin to transition out of that
data center mindset in many cases you're
gonna be I mean my experience has been
again and that most organizations of
that size are going to always be hybrid
they're going to have their data center
with their large ERP systems and others
that will remain in on on-prem but to be
able to manage that mindset across the
board it helps to have that cloud ops
team absolutely
[Music]